hey everyone i hope you're doing good
and staying safe i welcome you all to
this interesting tutorial on sql vs
nosql by simply learn as you know we are
living in a world that is full of data
and over the last few decades there has
been tremendous increase in the usage of
data globally and you can rightly say
that data is the new oil so in order to
store these large amounts of data we
need databases and there are a lot of
databases available in the market and in
today's session we'll focus on two major
types of databases that is sql and nosql
in today's session we'll understand what
exactly are these two databases and will
see the differences between these two
databases and when to use them but
before we get started if you're a tech
geek and love watching tech videos
consider getting subscribed to our
channel simply learn to stay updated
with all the latest technologies and hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from us so without any further ado let's
get started with today's topic
firstly let us go to the agenda for
today's session we'll start the tutorial
by understanding what is sql and then we
look at why we use sql and after that
we'll understand what is nosql database
and then we'll understand why we use
nosql up next we'll understand how to
use
nosql and how exactly it works and then
we'll look at some different types of
nosql databases and after that we'll
have a detailed comparison between sql
and osql database and finally we'll
conclude the session by understanding
some advantages and disadvantages of
using nosql and we'll also look when to
use sql as well as nosql so without any
further delay let us dive straight into
today's topic on sql versus nosql
firstly let us understand what is sql
sql as its stand is defined as structure
query language is basically a
standardized programming language that
is used to manage databases and it
performs various operations on data in
them initially created in 1970s sql is
widely used by many companies and
technologies nowadays
sql is used for modifying database
tables and
index structures it is also used in
adding updating and deleting rows of
data it is also used to retrieve subsets
of information from within the database
management system
now sql is used to perform various
actions such as to insert data to update
data modify and delete the data in the
database as well
now when we talk about sql it is
important that we talk about relational
database systems as well a relational
database system or rdm rdbms is a
database system that stores and fetches
data in the form of table that is in the
form of rows and columns tables are used
to store data and relational databases
about related objects each column
contains attributes of data whereas each
row holds a record of unique data known
as a key which helps in making
relationship between different data
points that is present in different
table which makes us easy to understand
now these relational databases or rdbms
are managed using sql language
to perform various operations therefore
sql codes are used to retrieve
information from these relational
databases by doing various interactive
operations like using join create
truncate delete alter and etc
let us now look at some popular sql
databases some popular sql databases
that are available are mysql oracle
database microsoft sql
server sqlite and postgresql
now that we have understood what is sql
let us now understand what is nosql
nosql database is a non-relational
database management system that does not
require a fixed schema that is the data
store is not stored in the form of
tables and nosql databases
basically it avoids any uh joining or
creating or scaling the databases in sql
the major purpose of using a nosql
database is for distributed data storage
which is having high volumes of data
storage needs nosql is used for big data
and real-time web applications like for
example companies like amazon facebook
google correct terabytes of users data
and every single day
so basically nosql database stands for
not only sql or not sql and
it is introduced in the year 1998 by
carl stross now traditional rdbms uses
sql syntax to store and retrieve data
for further insights now instead our
nosql database system
encompasses a wide range of database
technologies that can store structured
semi-structured
as well as unstructured data
let us now understand why we use nosql
we use
hierarchical storage structure instead
of a table like structure
that means uh before relational
databases companies used a hierarchical
databases terminator with a tree-like
structure for database tables now these
early database management systems
enabled users to organize large
quantities of data however they were
complex often required a particular
application and in a limited way which
they could uncover the data that is
stored now these limitations eventually
led to the development of relational
database that is the data that is stored
in tables
uh so a skill provided an interface to
interact with relational data and
allowing the analyst to connect tables
by merging on common fields but as time
passed the demand for faster and more
desperate usage of larger data sets
became increasingly more important for
emerging technologies for e-commerce and
other big giants for that uh nosql has
become the alternative for everyone
now another reason is it is now we have
constant addition of new features and
functions in the nosql database right
so that means like we know that
technology is being rapidly evolved and
huge enormous amounts of data has been
released on a daily basis and it's
important that we store this data and
access in a quick way now nosql is the
best database to use for large amounts
of data or for ever changing data sets
it is also best use when you have to uh
have a flexible data model or need that
don't fit into a relational model
and finally when if if you want that
there is no relationship between any
stored data and you feel it is not
important then you can use nosql as well
let us now look at some popular nosql
databases some popular noise called
databases are mongodb apache hedge base
cassandra redis neo4j and etc
let us now look at some types of nosql
databases that are present
firstly we have document oriented
the document database typically stores
self-describing json xml and bson
documents they are similar to key value
stores but in this case a value is a
single document that stores all the data
to related to a specific key popular
fields in the document can be indexed to
provide faster retrieval without knowing
the key as well each document can have
same or different data structure
mongodb couchdb cloudant are some
examples of document based nosql
database next we have key value pair
database the data in this is stored like
a key value pairs key value paired data
stored in database in the form of a hash
table each key is unique in this case
the value stored may be an integer
string a binary object a json object etc
the key value store based database is
simplest database among all the data
databases in nosql
database redis coherence are examples of
some key values to a databases
next we have column based or column
store database in nosql which is in this
the data stored in grouped columns
instead of rows every column values are
stored separately it delivers high
performance on aggregate functions like
count sum max minimum group of columns
are data stored in key spaces like
schema and rdbms key spaces contains
group of rows of columns
and hbase bigtable aculemo are some
examples of column store databases
and finally we have graph oriented or
graph store databases data in this is
represented in the form of a directed
graph it consists of nodes and edges
nodes represent an entity at any edge
represents the relation between the two
nodes node edge to be unique social
networks logistics patient data used a
graphical storage database neo4j
infinite graph orient db flog db are
examples of some graph storage database
next let us understand how exactly nosql
database works for that i am going to
take the example of mongodb
database now mongodb is based on the
nosql document store model in which data
objects are stored as separate documents
inside a collection instead of a
traditional column and row of a
relational database now
uh mongodb groups data through
collections and basically a collection
is simply a grouping of documents that
have a same or similar purpose a
collection acts similarly to a table in
a traditional sql database however it
has a major difference a collection is
not enforced by a strict schema that is
it does not have any fixed schema at all
instead documents in a collection can
have slightly different different
structure from another as needed this
reduces the need to break items in a
document into several different tables
at as it is often done in an sql
implementation now coming to document a
document is a representation of a single
entity of a data in mongodb database a
collection consists of one or more
related objects major difference that
exists between mongodb and sql in that
documents are different from rows row
data is flat with one column for each
value in the row however in mongodb
documents can contain embedded sub
documents providing a much closer
inherent data model for your
applications now if i just have to map
what are exactly and how it is different
from rdbms a collection in a mongodb is
equivalent to the tables in rdbms and a
document in mongodb is equivalent to the
rows in rdbms and fields in mongodb is
equivalent to the columns in rdbms
so this is how a document looks
uh in a mongodb as you can see this is
similar to a row in rdbms but we just
have a field and a value that is taken
separately instead of a tabular value
and another important thing to note here
is that a mongodb supports dynamic
schema which means one document of a
collection can have a number of fields
while the other document can have less
or same number of fields that is if a
collection can have
four fields while other document can
have only just two fields which is
basically not possible in a relational
database which does not exist it does
not support because it needs a
particular and a fixed schema in that if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know
more let us now understand some
differences between the sql and nosql
firstly sql is a relational database and
nosql is a non-relational database
that means sql databases are in the form
of tables that can contain rows and
columns and they have fixed logical
schema design all the data in sql is
arranged in tabular format and it is
well suited for complex queries and on
the other hand nosql databases is a
non-relational database that means it
does not store data in the form of
tables and contains collections and
inside every collection there is a
document that contains the data of a
single entry this data is stored in the
form of a key value pair unlike sql
where we store data under the fixed
schema
so as we discussed uh sql has a fixed
schema design and structure and nosql
has a dynamic schema design and
structure
sql can handle complex queries whereas
nosql can handle large volumes of data
now sql is vertically scalable
now
sql databases support vertical scaling
which means it improves the single
server by increasing ram ssd or cpu in
vertical scaling we are restricted to a
single system and we can improve it as
much as we want in the practical limit
whereas in nosql database we can do
horizontal scaling because they support
distributed computing or distributed
systems in horizontal scaling we can add
another node or computer for better
performance and we can add n number of
such servers or notes as per requirement
so as discussed we can add as many as
nodes as we want and this is why we
prefer nosql for high scalability
because there is no limit for scaling
and finally it follows acid properties
that is atomicity that means
transactions should be performed at once
or it shouldn't happen at all
consistency that means the state of a
database should remain consistent before
and after the transaction
isolation one transaction shouldn't
affect another transaction and should be
independent and we lastly durability now
successful transactions should be
reflected even if there is any system
failure whereas the nosql follows cap
property
that is consistency availability and
partial tolerance
let us now discuss some advantages and
disadvantages of using nosql firstly let
us discuss about the advantages
nosql provides high performance and
scalability and it also has a lot of
availability and flexibility it is open
source and it is schema-less as well
that is you can directly uh download the
nosql databases from the internet unlike
some commercial databases that are
available in the internet
while on the other hand there are some
disadvantages as well that is it lacks
the standardization that means it does
not have a fixed query uh in order to
retrieve data from the databases which
result in consistency issues and since
it has all these consistency issues and
does not retrieve data properly it has a
limited query capabilities
so that brings us to the end of today's
session on sql vs nosql guys so you
might have a doubt that when you need to
use sql and when we need to use nosql
now sql is easiest to work with
relational databases that is it is
useful when you want to perform complex
queries using various operations like
join and etc and if you want to perform
quick data storage and retrieval
operations you can use sql
whereas you can use nosql if you are
designing a distributed systems and if
you want a hierarchical storage
structure instead of a table like
structure
also nosql gives you the flexibility to
create dynamic structures and can add
features as you as you want
also there is no acid properties during
the creation of any applications while
creating nosql databases as well so in
this way you can use nosql and sql as
per your requirement with that we have
come to the end of session guys thank
you for watching the video i hope you
found this tutorial informative and
helpful if you have any further queries
regarding any of the topics that were
covered in today's session feel free to
let us know in the comment section below
and a team of experts will be more than
happy to resolve all your queries at the
earliest until next time stay safe and
keep coding
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here